brexit is one of the most divisive
political challenges of modern times
this is the deal that is on the table
this is the best possible deal it's the
only possible deal it's a leap in the
dark an ill-defined deal with a never
defined end date so who the main
character is taking part in this
bewildering psycho drama and what can we
discover about them by examining their
body language don't miss it yet the
Prime Minister has been desperately
trying to persuade everyone to back her
new deal more than ever before we find
that she's nodding her head to show her
interest and approval the nodding is
relentless
it makes her look like a toy but can't
stop bobbing its head up and down given
her desire to be persuasive
Teresa Mays nodding might also be a
subtle unconscious means of getting
people to mimic her and therefore to
give the impression that they agree with
her mr. Jeremy Corbyn the withdrawal
agreement is a leaf in the dark
very few people have a clue where Jeremy
Corbyn stands on brexit he's suitably
critical of the government but notice
how by reading from his notes he's able
to avoid making eye contact with the
members opposite while keeping his head
down literally as well as figuratively
his precious little knew to implement
spelt out in either the agreement or the
political declaration there are several
things that politicians do to give the
impression that they're tough and
dominant it keeps us in the e u--'s
regulatory framework forever
one is using large expansive gestures
means basically that we have failed in
our duty to the people to take back
control Boris Johnson's expressive
handguns often take up a lot of space
Theresa has been on the right love
here's one of his dominance gestures the
knuckles displayed he's actually
presenting the hard manly features of
his hands it's therefore a disguised
threat signal
Boris Johnson loves to make people laugh
I want to also to congratulate my friend
Philip Hammond for predicting that I
will never become Prime Minister
yesterday I saw you say which is the
first Treasury forecast in a long time I
think have a distinct ring of truth
being a source of amusement enables him
to generate a feel-good factor to put
people at ease and to enhance his
personal standing in their eyes so what
about the self-styled bad boys of
breakfast happy since George's Day
everybody
Nigel Faraj enjoys a good laugh he likes
to come across as approachable and
unassuming someone who wears his little
vices with pride another breaks it here
who's up for a larva is Erin banks for
both these men laughter provides a way
of presenting themselves as playful and
upbeat recently however things have
begun to change as the brexit day of
reckoning draws closer some of the
levers are started to look a lot more
serious they appear to have abandoned
their clown cars in favor of the
gravitas train
you've got Boris Johnson and David Davis
and you've got Dominic Robyn Estabrook
they you've got penny Morton you have
streams of talent within the
Conservative Party who would be very
capable of support of leading a proper
braixen Jacob Riis MOG doesn't exactly
come across as your macho politician
that's partly because he's got an
unusually long neck and a narrow face he
therefore lacks that essentially
masculine appearance that psychologists
refer to as formidable 'ti one way that
resmoke makes up for this is by speaking
slowly we all have our own
concerns hope spirits view of the world
and we can have empathy with other
peoples but we can't be other people's
and you certainly can't be two three
four or ten million people's view of the
world his measure delivery keeps his
distance waiting and discourages them
from interrupting giving the impression
that he's very much in control as what
my right honourable friend says and what
my right on Wilfred does no longer match
should I not write to my right on
girlfriend the member for Altrincham and
sail west it's another of the many
techniques that people in power use to
try and persuade everyone that they
deserve to be in charge
[Music]
when political leaders appear together
it's not always apparent how their
negotiations are going but by looking
closely at how they relate to each other
we can often tell who's got the upper
hand when the European chief negotiator
Michele Ponyo met up with David Davis
that then brexit secretary their body
language soon revealed who was in charge
pioneered for example is using more
expensive hand gestures Davis is
sporting a big smile for his Barney as a
pleasant expression a doesn't smile at
all because smiling serves as a
primitive appeasement signal this fakes
Davis looks like he's eager to please
while Barnea comes across as dominant
and workman like the Roosters call each
other
notice to how Barney is doing all the
talking reinforcing the impression that
he's calling the shops and good to see
you again David a similar pattern
emerges when Michel Barnier meets up
with an ex brexit secretary Dominic Robb
when the two men pose for the cameras
Rob is smiling broadly where his beining
hardly smiles at all
see how Barney a Orient's his body
towards the cameras making himself look
more imposing while Rob's body faces
more towards Barney making Bonnie a look
more important their patterns of gaze
say a lot about their relationship after
the handshake Barney a addresses the
press for just over two minutes while he
is speaking he only glances at robbed
twice amounting to less than three
percent of the time
Rob on the other hand addresses the
press for less than a minute and during
that time he looks at Barney a six times
amounting to more than the 16 percent of
the time he's talking here to Lansing at
the other person is a way of including
them showing that they are important
enough to deserve ones attention it's
linked to what psychologists call visual
dominance
Theresa May and European Commission
President jean-claude Juncker on meeting
in Brussels mrs. mayor good afternoon do
you expect you might get a deal their
actions seem innocent enough but let's
see what happens let me watch the same
event in slow motion it's a case of May
trying to adapt to Jonker rather than
the other way round
even before they've taken up their
positions they is monitoring yonkers
hand in anticipation of the handshake
it's only later that he glances down to
see if may is responding a similar thing
happens during the kiss
Janka takes the initiative pulling me
towards him so that she ends up
accommodating to him rather than
vice-versa it's Jung ko who signals that
the photoshoot is over by raising his
hand Mei appears to be caught off guard
because she's still smiling for the
cameras when Yuka has already started to
leave the scene since he's the host
it's yonkers job to take the initiative
and to be responsive instead we
repeatedly find him making a move an
expecting me to follow without giving
her time to respond or checking to see
if she's ready by behaving in this way
Janka is subtly asserting himself and
reminding everyone that he's top dog
yeah been shaken on my foot compare this
with a recent handshake between Theresa
May and German Chancellor Angela Merkel
watching in slow motion we see both
leaders check out the position of the
others hand may smiles and Merkel raises
her eyebrows and smiles - these are all
friendly appeasement signals see how
Merkel discreetly pumps May's hand to
indicate that the handshake is over and
they both let go at the same time tiny
considerate gestures like these show
that the two leaders are in sync with
each other but they're on the same page
[Music]
the characteristic and often unique ways
that the bricks of players behave tells
us a lot about them as individuals ought
to be a little easier one of former
foreign secretary Boris Johnson's famous
giveaways is his hair fluff it's an
integral feature of his personal brand
he'll ruffle his hair often making
himself look even more disheveled not
out of any need for self comfort but
because he's hoping to draw attention to
himself or because he's already
succeeded in doing so if Boris does ever
exhibit a need for self comfort it's
probably to be found in his habit of
putting his hands in his pockets
something he's inclined to do when he's
deciding what he's going to say on your
second question which was which was
there's no doubt that of all the
politicians who've been involved with
brexit tourism a has had the toughest
job it's therefore hardly surprising to
find that there been several occasions
when her composure has slipped and she's
unwittingly revealed her real feelings
for example it's not unusual for Teresa
made to produce a micro momentary fear
grimace when she's talking about an
emotionally upsetting issue or
struggling to explain a complicated idea
there's been some studies over the years
that have showed that in good times
companies they're more likely to appoint
men to leadership positions but in times
of crisis they're more likely to appoint
women look I think all I would say is
that I look at this as a politician as a
member of parliament as a prime minister
here's a typical sequence initially a
facial expression is under control all
of a sudden the corners of her mouth are
pulled out and moments later her
original facial expression has been
hurriedly reinstated the grimace only
last for a mere fraction of a second but
during that time it shows us what she's
really feeling it was Charles Darwin who
pointed out that facial expressions
consisting of opposite actions have
opposite meanings it follows therefore
that if lowered eyebrows communicate
dominance and threat when raised
eyebrows
no submissiveness and a desire to
reassure others if you watch Michael
Gove you'll notice that he frequently
raises his eyebrows when he interacts
with people regardless of whether they
more or less important than in his
achievement today but obviously there's
a message behind it what's your response
to his hits campaign well I think
Louis's an inspiration I think as well
as the grit and determination that he's
showed and in summoning this channel in
50 days he's also shown great leadership
in making us all aware of the vital
importance of the seas around our
Islands this is gos method for disarming
people is a reflex strategy for showing
that is not a threat
one of former you kept chief Nigel
Farage's Giveaways is the so-called
tongue show I know that virtually none
of you have ever done a proper job in
your lives when he's talking about
somebody or something he dislikes he
instinctively presses his tongue out
between his lips this is a regressive
gesture of rejection which owes its
origins to the babys habit of ejecting
its mother's breasts by sticking out its
tongue the tongue show is entirely
unconscious
Faraj doesn't have a faintest clue that
he's showing his displeasure in this way
nor do the people at whom the gesture is
directed most politicians are totally
unaware of their giveaways because these
behaviors are produced unconsciously and
unwittingly they often give us a special
insight into what individual politicians
are really like
[Music]
how people react when journalists are
lying in wait to ambush them with
questions tells us a lot about their
attitudes to the media and how they want
to be seen we can all shoot the lead one
response is the push off here a
businessman Phillip Green makes it
painted it clear that he wants nothing
to do with the media even to the point
of trying to prevent any filming
politicians responses to door stepping
are usually less dramatic watch how
Jeremy Corbyn runs the media gauntlet
moving as fast as he can from his front
door to his bicycle or the escape
vehicles good morning how nice to see
you while simultaneously making sure
that none of the waiting journalists are
able to catch his eye by studiously
averting his gaze he's showing them that
he's not available to counteract any
impression that he's being rude
Corbin adopts a half-hearted smile at
the same time he produces a rapid-fire
battery of utterances like good morning
nice to see you and goodbye
can you fix the relationship mr. gorban
good bye now these stereotyped remarks
might seem polite but they are merely a
pretense at politeness and rather grumpy
one at that their real purpose is to
keep up a constant chatter demonstrating
the Corbett is not listening while
making it virtually impossible for
anyone to ask him a question without
talking over him but these aren't the
only evasive tricks that Corbin has up
his sleeve he seems to be equally
content for people like his
mother-in-law to act as a human shield
between himself and the media
Boris Johnson's response to door
stepping is very different the
government sends an outside session
there are occasions where he clearly
wants to avoid any interaction and we're
like Corbin he puts up a smokescreen of
words to discourage journalists from
asking him awkward questions I wanted a
quiet walk to work that's what I was the
big difference however is that Boris
usually does so with a big beaming smile
but there are also times when Boris
seems more intent on buttering up the
journalist notice the welcoming
expression on Boris his face the
slightly flared nostrils and that
incipient smile suggesting that he's
excited and enjoying the media attention
also the beguiling way he flatters the
people present in order to get them on
his side and you've been incredibly
patient and incredibly and I feel very
sorry for you because I have nothing to
say about this man except it's as if
Boris was saying I'm so sorry chaps I
can't answer your questions how about a
tray of sweet talk instead fellow brexit
campaigner michael gove is different
again like boris is happy to engage with
the media but unlike boris he responds
to the questions that are put to him
rather he goes through the motions of
doing so
I think primers are doing a very good
job and I think it's important that
people do give the fly master all the
support they can in order to ensure that
she concludes the deal it's in the best
interest of Britain because if you're
listening carefully you'll realize that
when go does give an answer
it's often to a completely different
question to the one who's just been
asked would you resign if she doesn't
make the late changes B prime is - by
full support
we also find go flattering the
journalist
and manage to get to him a lovely
evening secrets lovely see you he
apologizes for any discomfort
she has to it do you listen where you
have to walk backwards and Susan where
that illicit Opel here oh yes absolutely
it's all designed to make him look
considerate and to get the journalist
and the viewing public on side notice
those raised eyebrows it goes signature
expression his way of showing that even
though is an important politician he is
not a threat what will we've got a much
more progressive policy on agriculture
and the environment and the EU it's
often at times like these when
politicians are being pursued by the
media that they reveal what kind of
person they really are
[Music]
there are two worlds which are utterly
different one is the sphere of politics
the other that have danced while
politics is scheming conceited and often
mind-numbing ly boring dances
spontaneous life-affirming and joyful
recently these two worlds have collided
with each other the results I'm afraid
were not always a pretty picture it all
began on Teresa Mays recent visit to
Kenya when a local Scout started dancing
and she joined in doing her best to pick
up the beat and to copy the movements it
was the prime ministerial equivalent of
dad dancing the leaders speech at last
year's Conservative Party conference was
a disaster government businesses and the
public sector working together we have
bounced back we've created record
numbers of jobs bits of the stage
collapsed Teresa may struggle with a
hacking cough and to capital a prankster
tried to present her with her p45 while
our opponents flirt with a foreign
policy of neutrality and prepare for a
run on the ground it was decided this
year's conference was going to be
different it would be positive and
uplifting and the secret weapon would be
dancing
[Music]
when she mounted the stage to the
strains of ABBA
we saw may as we've never seen her
before
seemingly relaxed and swaying in time to
the music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here was a rhythmic rebranding of the
prime-minister a boogying attempt to
distance her from last year's disaster
and to present her as undeterred and
trendy did it work
not really partly because her style was
so unusual but also because the whole
exercise seemed so comedic and out of
character it looked like the Prime
Minister had started a jitterbug craze
because soon afterwards jean-claude
juncker was also grooving on stage his
impromptu contribution was actually a
mocking reference to Teresa may's antics
and his audience obviously loved it
Jeremy Colvin likes to encourage
everyone to start clapping but he seems
to have less interest in joining in with
the crowd once it gets going
once he does join in he's able to pick
up the beat but moments later he loses
[Music]
while everyone else is clapping in
unison : looks like he's listening to a
completely different tune musically is
not in the same page as those around him
he's out on a limb placing the brexit
players under the microscope gives us a
much clearer picture of their personal
goals and strategies as well as their
foibles and shortcomings anything that
enhances our understanding of these
politicians is to be welcomed especially
these are uncertain and troubling times
[Music]
you